merci d'être avec nous et nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure c'est matrice centriste du
Nord vice-présidente du Sénat on va
parler du Zéro artificialisation net des
sols c'est un sujet d'inquiétude pour
les élus c'est un texte que vous portez
mais d'abord l'actualité c'est toujours
la réforme des retraites vous êtes à
soutenu vous samedi soir lors du vote
sur cette réforme pourquoi bien d'abord
j'essaie d'écouter la voix des
populations que je représente aussi j'ai
des valeurs j'ai des idées je suis
centriste je suis pour que l'on
travaille sur l'avenir de nos retraites
il faut réformer les retraites mais vous
le savez je l'ai déjà exprimé
la temporalité la façon dont c'est
construit la méthode de construction de
cette réforme peut-être passer de
concertation en amont faire venir ça au
moment où on connaît la crise de
l'énergie liée effectivement et du
pouvoir d'achat l'inflation un conflit
russe ukrainien qui ont inquiété nos
concitoyens qui ont affaibli leur
pouvoir pas leur parler réforme des
retraites et dans un contexte où
effectivement il y a peut-être pas eu
suffisamment de préparation de pédagogie
et de partage de co-construction avec
les partenaires sociaux et les
parlementaires ça démarrait mal et dans
cette dans ce texte si par exemple sur
les 43 ans moi j'étais favorable la
mesure d'âge très honnêtement je pense
qu'elle impacte fortement des personnes
qui sont des gens en fragilité par
rapport à l'accès une retraite complète
et il me semblait que
d'une part le Sénat a fait quelques
avancées sociales sur la retraite des
femmes justement sur cette précarité qui
va se renforcer à trouver quelques
solutions qui pouvaient améliorer un peu
les choses mais quand même la mesure
d'âge ne me convient pas donc je me suis
absolument pour qui quand même
discussion en CMP et qu'on puisse sur
quelques avancées voilà être force de
proposition pour autant je ne partage
pas la mesure d'âge il y a un autre
point par exemple qui m'a aussi beaucoup
chagriné j'ai ma collègue fermé qui a
déposé un amendement elle est à la
commission des finances qui visait à
faire en sorte que les les gains de CSG
liés à deux années de cotisation s'il y
a à mesure d'âge au moins puisse aller
vers un fond de réserve des retraites on
demande aux Français de faire un effort
en acceptant des mesures de travail et
de cotisation supplémentaire pour
réduire les déficits équilibrés on
dégage des marges de manœuvre on doit
les mettre dans un fond de réserve
plutôt que de les mettre dans le pot
commun parce que qui dit effort pour les
retraites sanctuarisation des moyens
pour les retraites ça me paraissait une
bonne mesure elle a été rejetée mais
typiquement moi je trouve que c'était
vertueux de dire ben on fait des efforts
ça part pour nos retraites futures tout
ça ça fait un équilibre qui ne me
convenait pas des gens inquiets qui
comprennent pas sur quoi nous allons
atterrir réformer les retraites oui mais
on sait qu'en plus le gain budgétaire va
être assez faible et donc on devra
remettre ça sur le tapis on a fragilisé
quand même le dial l'époque entre le
gouvernement le peuple et même le
Parlement il faut reconstruire un
travail une coproduction travailler tous
ensemble avec les corps intermédiaires
on va parler de ça mais sur le fond
est-ce que vous espérez encore des
améliorations sur ce texte est-ce que
vous demandez encore des améliorations
parce que le parcours législatif n'est
pas terminé les améliorations je vous ai
dit c'est d'abord
sur les 43 ans notamment on sait que ce
que vous dites est partagé par des
députés républicains par des députés
horizons est-ce que vous espérez qu'en
commission mixparitaire les choses
changent mais écoutez je pense que
aujourd'hui la commission mixte
paritaire en tout cas côté Sénat je
pense que les élus partent avec un
certain nombre de propositions de
maintien d'avancer qui ont été portés
effectivement
au Sénat après qu'est-ce que ça va
effectivement donner comment les membres
de la commission mixte paritaire peuvent
s'entendre sur des lignes telles que les
43 ans ou la mesure d'âge ou
moi je pense qu'il peut y avoir un
accord de CMP mais après je ne lis pas
dans le marc de café du tout on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui les choses sont
fragiles que tout le monde s'interroge
que l'équilibre à trouver aujourd'hui
l'équilibré est plus que précaire
comment ça va atterrir qu'est-ce qui va
se passer si effectivement après ça
repart vers l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui
très difficile ça veut dire que
l'utilisation du 49-3 pour vous sur ce
texte ce serait un problème
le 49-3 enfin ça a mal commencé c'est à
dire qu'on ait eu l'impression que c'est
quelque chose que quelque chose arrivé
de façon extrêmement verticale peu
co-produite alors on nous parle de
concertation la concertation elle
ressemble plus à une information des
partenaires sociaux ou des
parlementaires qu'à une coproduction
alors ça commence difficilement dans la
douleur il faut pas que ça se termine
dans la douleur et par un divorce entre
encore une fois le Parlement les corps
intermédiaires la population et le
gouvernement il faut essayer de
reconstituer un dialogue une capacité à
travailler ensemble mais pour ça dès le
départ il faut créer les conditions le
problème c'est quand ça démarre
difficilement c'est compliqué et 49-3
c'est pas vraiment la démocratie
parlementaire
ça va laisser des traces pour vous cette
bataille est-ce que déjà ça va laisser
des traces au sein de votre groupe il y
a 20 sénateurs sur les 57 du groupe
Union centriste qui n'ont pas vos tests
le groupe Union centriste c'est un
groupe où
sur les fondamentaux les valeurs que
nous partageons il y a une union totale
mais il y a une liberté de parole et sur
un texte qui impacte autant les Français
et avec des réalités territoriales très
divers moi je viens d'un département du
Nord où les gens qui ont pas de carrière
complète parce qu'on a vécu la fermeture
de l'industrie sidérurgique des
houillères on a des tas de gens qui
voulaient travailler mais qui ont perdu
leur emploi et qui pendant des années
n'en ont pas retrouvé on a des tas de
gens qui sont aujourd'hui dans des
carrières ou avec des retraites des
carrières hachées des retraites qui
seront petites avec des femmes qui sont
temps partiel subit tout ça va impacter
la population les plus fragiles se
sentent pas rassurés parce qu'il est en
train de se passer moi j'entends je sais
qu'il faudra y revenir il travailler
mais j'espère qu'à l'avenir ceux qui
sortira pour garantir les retraites
durablement et bien nous soyons en
capacité de le faire ensemble et de le
faire en donnant le sentiment de justice
Vous regrettez que le gouvernement est
que la majorité sénatoriale de la droite
et du centre en tout cas dans sa
majorité n'est pas suffisamment entendu
les Français moi je pense que le Sénat a
raison de travailler et d'aller au bout
du débat et de voter un texte parce que
sinon c'est la négation effectivement du
parlementarisme et on est là pour porter
une voix après on s'est exprimé dans
notre diversité la majorité sénatorielle
s'est exprimée je pense que
enfin voilà moi je respecte tout à fait
il y a beaucoup de gens qui veulent
qu'on avance sur cette réforme des
retraites la difficulté c'est que on est
parti d'un texte qui nous a été posé qui
a beaucoup de sujets que ce soit les
régimes spéciaux que ce soit
effectivement même l'avancée de l'âge
des parents retraite ces conditions on
les a pas suffisamment travaillé avec
enfin voilà avec le gouvernement vous
êtes on subit
vous êtes vice-présidente du Sénat on a
vu des débats au Sénat tendus comme
rarement est-ce que ça va les aider
traces au Sénat entre la majorité
sénatoriale et la gauche
je pense que
on rentre sur des sujets extrêmement
sensibles
qui qui voilà font que un certain nombre
de de valeurs qui sont
intrinsèques effectivement composants de
politique font que ce débat c'est
différent elle s'exprime comme elle ne
s'était pas exprimée depuis longtemps
pour autant le Sénat est une assemblée
qui respecte ces différences et qui sait
se retrouver sur les sujets d'intérêt
général on va parler d'usage ensuite
s'il y a bien un sujet sur lequel de
façon extrêmement transpartisane on
partage le point de vue d'une réalité
territoriale sur lequel on doit défendre
les collectivités par rapport à un texte
et des objectifs de la loi climat que
tout le monde partage mais la méthode
très verticale une fois de plus et bien
de la gauche jusqu'à la droite tout le
monde est convaincu qu'il faut desserrer
les taux et que c'est pas possible que
tout descende comme ça on va parler du
zan zéro artificialisation nette des
sols c'est un texte que vous portez que
dans le Sénat a débuté l'examen hier
c'est un sujet d'inquiétude pour les
élus locaux on va en parler on accueille
Steve jourdains qui va nous détailler le
texte et nous raconter la séance d'hier
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour madame
qui prévoit d'améliorer le dispositif
actuel en matière d'artificialisation
des sols avant d'entrer dans le détail
Steve rappelez-nous très simplement ce
qu'est l'artificialisation des sols et
quels sont les règles qui existent
aujourd'hui
artificialisé ces bétonné c'est
peut-être plus parlant dit comme ça
bétonner bétonné bétonné en France on
est très fort en la matière puisque
qu'entre 6 et 9% du territoire est
considéré comme artificialisé
artificialisé on est tout simplement le
pays le plus bétonné d'Europe par
habitant chaque année entre 20000 et
30000 hectares de terrains sont
concernés en moyenne dans l'Hexagone
alors artificialiser un sol ça veut dire
le transformer c'est utile car ça permet
de créer des surfaces consacrées par
exemple à l'habitat le problème c'est
que ces sols ne remplissent alors plus
leurs fonctions naturelles il faut
savoir qu'un seul artificialisé
n'absorbe plus de CO2 il participe donc
au réchauffement climatique c'est cette
tendance que le gouvernement souhaite
renverser une loi a donc adopté Oriane
et la loi climat est résilience
qu'est-ce qu'elle prévoit et pourquoi
elle est critiquée par les Sénats
objectif 0 artificialisation net c'est
ce qui est prévu par la loi qui impose
aux collectivités de diminuer de 50%
d'ici à 2031 le rythme de bétonisation
des terres à terme l'objectif et bien
c'est d'arriver à zéro artificialisation
en 2050 l'objectif est très ambitieux le
problème et bien c'est que les textes
d'application pris par l'exécutif ne
sont pas adaptés à la situation sur le
terrain les collectivités n'ont pas les
outils adaptés pour répondre à l'enjeu
de la transition le calendrier pose
aussi question bref beaucoup de sujets
dont le gouvernement dit avoir
conscience tout le monde est d'accord il
faut changer la loi
ce dispositif il a été il a été adopté
dans le cadre de la loi climat et
résilience un texte de 35 articles
il a soulevé à la fois une forme
d'enthousiasme par le fait que la France
puisse prendre ce sujet de la lutte
contre l'étalement urbain à bras le
corps et parfois des difficultés de mise
en oeuvre ou des incompréhensions dans
la manière dont les choses à se passer
et pour répondre à la colère des élus
locaux plus de pragmatismes c'est-à-dire
plus de simplicité et aussi plus de
temps pour mettre en oeuvre les
objectifs fixés au niveau national la
majorité sénatoriale milite pour un
meilleur partage de l'effort entre État
et collectivités elle souhaite aussi
mettre à disposition des élus locaux de
nouveaux outils pour faciliter la
transition à cela le gouvernement dit
why not pourquoi pas mais attention à ne
pas perdre de vue les objectifs fixés en
matière environnementale écoutez on ne
va pas arrêter de construire la priorité
elle est d'organiser une sobriété
foncière
qui est le prolongement de ce que les
élus locaux ont d'ores et déjà commencé
au travers des chiffres
d'artificialisation
vous vous êtes sur la même ligne avec le
gouvernement vous partagez les mêmes
priorités on partage les mêmes objectifs
comme la vous l'avez très bien rappelé
comme la rappeler le ministre
la loi climat c'est une évidence pour
tous les élus de France et de Navarre se
dire qu'il faut être plus sobre garantir
la sobriété foncière protéger les
espaces agricoles naturels et forestiers
c'est une évidence pour autant le pays
ne s'arrête pas il faut continuer à
faire vivre les territoires à faire en
sorte que et bien
les sous la souveraineté industrielle
voulue par le gouvernement la transition
industrielle vers une industrie propre
nécessite qu'on a par exemple qu'on
implante des gigafactory qui vont
consommer du foncier des communes
rurales qui ont besoin de continuer à
accueillir des familles jeunes dans le
respect encore une fois d'une
consommation foncière maîtrisée c'est à
dire qu'on va pas effectivement
autoriser des parcelles de terrain
immense pour accueillir un logement tout
le monde a bien conscience et à créer
des documents d'urbanisme plus sobre
donc là vous demandez d'assouplir le
revenir sur les objectifs on a
d'ailleurs dit que nous étions d'accord
sur les objectifs qui ont été votés dans
la loi climat mais simplement un peu
comme sur les retraites pouvoir partager
cette mise en oeuvre d'un urbanisme plus
sobre plus maîtrisé mais effectivement
divisé par de la consommation foncière
est déjà un énorme effort pour les
collectivités qui vont devoir réviser
leurs documents d'urbanisme et faire en
sorte de de déclasser de rendre à la
nature la moitié des espaces qui étaient
à la construction il faut savoir vous
avez donné des chiffres mais que depuis
10 ans même plus de 10 ans
les Scotts Grenelle étaient déjà des
scottes qui propos divisé par 2 3 4 la
surface consommée par rapport aux années
aux décennies précédentes depuis 10 ans
il y a une tendance à la baisse de la
consommation foncière cette loi elle
veut aller encore plus loin mais ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'il y a bien
longtemps que les élus locaux se sont
mis en ordre de marche sans le passer
par la contrainte pour justement
reconquérir les frichonnes industries
alors concrètement expliquez-nous
qu'est-ce qui inquiète les élus locaux
voir qu'est-ce qui les agacent qu'est-ce
qu'ils vous font remonter ces élus
locaux les élus locaux ils vont un zinc
qui est en fait un zéro
artificialisation net un texte de loi
qui propose une application extrêmement
corseté c'est la région qui va parce que
le ministre nous disait voilà la loi
climat vous l'avez votée maintenant
happy qu'on l'a mais on a voté un texte
qui donnait une tendance qui donnait des
objectifs à atteindre aux collectivités
aux régions aux intercos aux communes
décret d'application qui n'est pas la
loi va plus loin dit sa s'impose à vous
c'est prescriptif et aujourd'hui on
demande aux régions d'écrire un grand
scotch régional un grand document
d'urbanisme régional qui va s'imposer à
toutes les collectivités qui va être
extrêmement contraint prescriptif et qui
va leur demander de d'appliquer très
fortement des règles communes à tous ce
qu'on dit c'est que il faut
effectivement que la région donne un cap
des objectifs ambitieux
répartissent des consommations foncières
qu'il faudra maîtriser mais laissons un
peu de souplesse au collectivité donnons
du temps pour que la région puisse
dialoguer avec ces territoires pour
regarder comment on prépare cette
nouvelle organisation aujourd'hui si on
n'a pas un an de délai dans un mois va
s'imposer effectivement aux régions la
nécessité délibérée de répartir des
enveloppes foncières alors qu'on ne
connaît pas encore tous les contours de
ce zen puisqu'on en débat encore dans la
loi pour autant le compte à rebours est
parti depuis 2021 les régions se voient
imposer les choses elles doivent être au
rendez-vous elles doivent délibérées sur
quelque chose qui n'est pas ficelé à ce
jour on est un peu entre deux eaux et
donc il faut du temps il faut un an
délai supplémentaires pour se mettre en
ordre de marche sans bouger les délais
les dates et les objectifs mais du temps
pour construire tout ça avec les
collectivités donner aussi la
possibilité de desserrer les taux en
imposant pas en plus de la division par
deux de l'effort qu'il faudra faire et
bien d'intégrer des grands projets
nationaux tous ces grands projets
sortent des quotas régionaux c'est ça
voilà soit compté à part il faut savoir
que on a consommé 250 000 hectares sur
les dix années 2011 2021 le zan c'est
dit vous allez diviser par de ce qui est
énorme parce que avec ces ça on fait les
logements sociaux les maisons de santé
les écoles on travaille sur des
implantations économiques parce qu'il
faut bien créer de l'emploi on en
reparlera peut-être tout à l'heure mais
il faut être plus vertueux il faut
réduire partout on peut reconstruire sur
la ville on le fait ça un coup il faut
aller reconquérir nos friches faut bien
les les connaître il faut créer
l'ingénierie les outils pour l'instant
tout cela n'est pas encore prêt c'est à
dire que là on travaille sur
l'architecture du zinc ce texte nous dit
comment on doit avancer nous on dit
attention du temps la prescriptivité on
n'est pas d'accord un délai d'un an
attention que les projets d'intérêt
nationaux vont venir s'ajouter à cet
effort dans les territoires et que on va
finir par être dans une situation qui
sera compliquée il faut continuer à
laisser respirer la ruralité il faut que
la ruralité garde un droit au projet il
faut pas qu'on se retrouve dans une
situation où l'exercice contraint
d'application de cette sobriété foncière
ne garantissent pas un équilibre entre
le besoin de la ruralité de l'urbanité
de l'Éc tout en respectant ses enjeux il
faut de la souplesse il faut construire
entre l'État la Région et les
collectivités quelque chose de partagé
et non pas d'imposer c'est la méthode
encore une fois sur laquelle nous
demandons de la souplesse est-ce que ce
débat que vous avez actuellement avec le
gouvernement c'est pas les illustrations
il peut y avoir une contradiction entre
la préservation de l'environnement et
puis la défense des intérêts économiques
qui sont nécessaires utiles surtout sur
le terrain mais on est vous savez les
collectivités elles sont en bas de
l'entonnoir donc c'est que des
injonctions contradictoires on dit on a
vécu le covid on dit il faudrait
peut-être être capable de reproduire
demain du doliprane mais une usine pour
faire ça c'est des hectares et du
foncier qu'on peut pas toujours mettre
sur une friche parce que ce sont des
grandes parcelles qu'il faut et on n'a
pas toujours de disponible les parcelles
correspondantes partout on peut
requalifier des friches on l'a déjà fait
on les réaffecte à du logement à de
l'économie quelquefois on ne peut pas on
nous demande par exemple de reporter de
réduire les émissions de CO2 canal senor
dans les Hauts-de-France le canal senor
c'est enlever les poids lourds de
l'autoroute pour les mettre sur une
barge pas d'émission de CO2 on nous dit
vous enlevez de votre compte foncière
régional 2400 hectares parce que vous
consommez du foncier parce qu'à chaque
fois que vous retirez des sédiments du
canal que vous les posez dans une
peinture on considère que cette espace
est artificialisée donc on vous enlève
2400 hectares de droits à construire les
élus comprennent pas ils font l'effort
d'investir de financer massivement
quelque chose qui convient aux enjeux de
climat et d'un autre côté on leur dit
attention vous êtes consommateur de
fonciers on est en fait on vous faites
une gigafactory pour préparer le
véhicule propre de demain vous consommez
du foncier ces projets là on dit vous
les déduisez votre enveloppe régionale
évidemment mais du coup que reste-t-il
est-ce que ça a aussi un impact pour les
particuliers pour les gens qui nous
regardent sur la construction de
logements est-ce que pour demain ça veut
dire moins de construction de logements
des logements auteurs des parcelles de
simple plus petite bien sûr ça veut dire
que on va devoir transformer notre façon
de construire la vie il va falloir
densifier les territoires urbains
réduire les parcelles qui seront
consommées par exemple pour du logement
individuel dans la ruralité ça veut dire
aller plus de grand terrain
aujourd'hui c'est pas dit comme cela
mais par la par la force des choses
quand vous avez moins d'hectares à
consommer et bien vous vous essayez
d'être plus sobre plus vertueux et de
réduire les parcelles utilisées mais
mais ça se fera naturellement sans qu'il
y ait besoin de contraintes c'est parce
que les documents d'urbanisme devront
répondre à plus de besoins avec moins de
terrains mais ça va aussi renchérir le
foncier mettre en concurrence un projet
économique une maison de santé du
logement social une implantation
industrielle sur un même territoire
quand on a un droit à construire limité
quel choix fait-on faire un logement
social ça coûte très très cher le fait
d'avoir moins de terrains de fonciers ça
va augmenter le prix du foncier quand on
vous dit il faut refaire des logements
sociaux ou de l'économie sur une friche
une friche faut la dépolluer la
viabiliser la réaménager avant de
construire vous avez déjà un coup ça
veut dire que très vite derrière ce
débat que nous avons il faut que le
gouvernement pose les questions de son
financement de son ingénierie parce que
on a la Fédération Nationale des Travaux
publics qui nous a dit
requalifier les friches on considère que
ça coûtera entre 2 milliards et demi et
3 milliards d'euros aujourd'hui on a un
fond friche il est 450 millions d'euros
il est déjà affecté il y a un sujet de
financement de fiscalité d'usane
d'ingénierie pour réussir cela et bien
il faut en même temps laisser la place
aux collectivités dans la gouvernance
donner des outils qui vont permettre aux
élus de gérer cette période
intermédiaire il faut véritablement
aujourd'hui quelques souplesse quelques
aménagements et derrière il faudra très
vite les moyens merci Steve merci
regarde on parlera d'une certaine CMP
tout à l'heure
ce sera sur dans le club on va continuer
à parler de cette question d'usane qui
faut-il l'actualité dans votre
département du Nord on va y aller
justement à Lille où on retrouve pierre
Jérôme Montenot rédacteur en chef de
WeHo c'est la télévision locale du Nord
il a une question pour vous Valérie
l'État sur la mobilisation des
agriculteurs contre l'implantation d'une
usine de batterie on l'écoute bonjour
madame Letard
fin février les agriculteurs de la
région de du Quesnoy près de
Valenciennes on manifesté contre
l'implantation d'une usine de
composantes de batterie le motif de la
colère c'est l'implantation sur 50
hectares de terres agricoles et il n'y a
pas de friche industrielle disponibles à
côté cette usine doit employer 1600
personnes selon les prévisions les plus
optimistes alors voici ma question
est-ce que la réindustrialisation peut
se faire au détriment de l'agriculture
merci beaucoup
je vous laisse répondre et bien c'est
toute la difficulté qui se posent à
toutes les collectivités c'est que
effectivement vous vous retrouvez tout
en bas de l'entonnoir comme je vous
disais avec des enjeux de souveraineté
alimentaire d'agriculture de terres
agricoles à protéger ou à compenser
parce que ça aussi ça fait partie des
choses qu'il faut réfléchir on parle
d'un territoire où les agriculteurs se
manifestent et un des territoires du
Nord qui a le plus fort taux de chômage
qui a perdu son industrie qui a besoin
de se reconvertir ou véritablement il y
a besoin de redynamiser l'emploi on ne
peut pas laisser des territoires morts
pour autant on comprend que les
agriculteurs qui ont des terres fertiles
souhaitent garder cela comme je vous
l'expliquais tout à l'heure la question
qui se pose c'est on a des gigafactory
on veut demain avoir notre souveraineté
par rapport à la capacité à produire des
batteries ou les postons les hauts de
France c'est au carrefour de l'Europe du
Nord dans une stratégie européenne de
souveraineté par rapport à tout cela la
des Hauts de France c'est le territoire
qui implante 3 gigafactory mais ces
gigafactory production de batterie ils
ont besoin de pièces d'éléments de
composants sans lesquels ça ne peut pas
fonctionner ou les poser si tout le
débat du zan et ce débat du sein c'est
et d'ailleurs Toyota qui était le
symbole de la renaissance du Nord s'est
fait sur des terres agricoles si on
n'avait pas eu cette parcelle agricole
aucune friche n'était capable
d'accueillir une usine comment les
compense-t-on c'est ça qu'il faut voir
comment est-on capable de renaturer de
rendre des terres agricoles en
compensation aux agriculteurs ou mettre
effectivement l'industrie à chaque fois
qu'on peut le mettre sur une friche on
le fait là la discussion c'est dans le
Nord dans ce territoire où trouvera-t-on
les 50 hectares pour accueillir cet
indispensable unité de production sans
laquelle nos giga Factory seront en
difficulté c'est
ces injonctions ces percussions entre
des objectifs qui sont tous essentiels
et qu'il faut trancher ce sujet il pose
aussi la question de la décentralisation
vous nous en avons parlé Emmanuel Macron
a réuni les associations d'élus lundi à
l'Élysée il parle de vrais
décentralisation vous y croyez à une
vraie décentralisation durant second
quinquennat à condition que
décentralisation soit bien
décentralisation pour ma
décentralisation c'est véritablement ne
pas mettre sous tutelle fiscal
financière autonomie fiscale ou tutelle
financière aujourd'hui la fiscalité des
collectivités on a supprimé la CVAE la
taxe d'habitation aux collectivité sauf
que il faut savoir que la libre
administration des collectivités elle se
traduit par une capacité à pouvoir agir
au plus près de la population en ayant
les leviers et la ressource et en
rendant compte de cette ressource
à ces administrées qu'est-ce que je fais
de ma fiscalité comment je laffecte et
comment je suis un partenaire de l'État
ça c'est la décentralisation l'état
assez compétences régaliennes les
collectivités Région Département
communes interco avait défiscalités on
les a supprimés on les a remplacés par
des dotations le problème c'est qu'on
est un peu sous tutelle financière le
zan c'est une forme de tutelle normative
qui vient s'ajouter la décentralisation
c'est dire il faut rendre des
compétences de proximité aux
collectivité mais leur donner les moyens
de l'autonomie pour être partenaire de
l'État et non des agents de l'État la
décentralisation c'est pas la
déconcentration l'état partenaire des
collectivités chacun dans ses
compétences l'état stratège les
collectivités agissent mais on leur
donne l'autonomie pour être responsable
devant leurs administrés merci Valérie
Létard merci beaucoup la suite de
l'examen de votre texte c'est jeudi soir
au Sénat puisque c'est pas terminé il y
a encore beaucoup d'amendements